hello
it's a Rybak menhir your host for the
future of health now calm the purpose of
our site is to give you privileged
access to some of the world's greatest
doctors scientists and thought leaders
helping you to live the healthiest life
possible and today we have the honor of
speaking with rich role he is a ultraman
endurance athlete who only started
training recently in his early 40s and
the best part is that he's a vegan I
didn't even know it was possible to
compete at those levels as a vegan he's
really caught the whole world by storm
I'm really excited for us to have this
in-person interview for you here in
Kauai enjoy and today we're here and we
have the honor of speaking with rich
roll hi everybody
I didn't bring my medical degree it's ok
it's ok
just this time just this time rich
riches the riches a very very
fascinating man his book recently came
out it's entitled finding ultra ok I'll
put a link to it in Amazon for you in
this post and I really do encourage any
of you better that feel inclined to take
a look at it to read it it's absolutely
amazing I just want to share with you a
few of the notes I took down here for
Rich's biome and I'll give I'll give
I'll give more of this information below
in the post and in detail so you can
read much more on him but riches that
he's a wellness advocate on behalf of
predominantly plant-based nutrition the
one thing that I'm going to share with
you at the end that totally surprised me
when I learned this about rich but he's
an entertainment attorney he's a husband
and father of four children who I think
I've met almost all four of them so far
yes oh yeah beautiful beautiful kids
Rich's book finding ultra was just
released this past summer and in only
less than four months five months now
he sold almost 40,000 copies already
right great yeah it's done really well
it was a
number one in a couple categories on
Amazon for quite a long time the
paperback is coming out this spring so
it will breathe a little bit of a new
life into it but yes exceeded my wildest
expectations and the book is doing great
and I'm really couldn't be happier more
proud mostly because I feel like I wrote
the book that I wanted to write yeah
like I wasn't trying to make it work for
a certain audience or that I was really
just kind of telling my story as
authentically and it's honestly and
openly and it's vulnerably as I could
and and I think that's a reason why it
seems to have resonated
you haven't heard of it or fried chicken
out yeah check it out it's amazing I'm
will put the Kindle link here as well
now this is also really cool rich just
recently started his very own podcast
which is called the rich roll podcast
such creative man totally creative new
and in three weeks
he's already he at the very outside he
taught the very top of iTunes for all of
health and wellness and right now so far
in three weeks he's already received
65,000 downloads and it's number four as
of last night I checked it I was number
four overall for all a health and
wellness which is incredible
like that there are people that have
been doing this for years that represent
the top three positions so clearly what
rich is doing is really resonating with
a lot of people and I want to share with
you sort of what what that is so you can
learn a lot more about this in his book
but when Rich was thirty nine he was
pretty average I would say pretty
average guy he was an entertainment
lawyer father he wasn't in very good
shape he had a pretty typical diet he
ate fast food ate pretty much whatever
he wanted kind of whenever he felt like
it he had a personal experience where he
really wanted to change his physical
well-being if you will you know expound
on that we could expand we can't we can
expand yeah yeah so yeah that's exactly
right I mean I had been 46 years old
right now I had been a swimmer in
college so I had a background as an
athlete but you know when when college
was over that was the end of my athletic
career and kind of anything sort of
physically aspirational so my life
became about you know climbing the
corporate ladder I went to law school
you know getting the best law firm job
getting on the partnership track and you
know there's there's more layers to the
story there's a there's a battle with
drug and alcohol addiction yeah that's
in there as well we can talk about that
if you want but but the in a nutshell
really
now I was sort of pursuing and leading
the kind of typical American male
you know lifestyle and pursued
throughout my 20s and 30s just trying to
get ahead in the world and kind of
putting into action all of those things
that were taught as kids like you know
get good grades get into the best school
that you can get into get into the best
college and then it's about the best job
and then it's about moving upwards and
what's your salary and you know who that
car just came out kind of accumulating
the kind of trappings and possessions
that come along with that and I really
kind of played that game you know I
played that game well and by all
accounts really from from an outsider's
perspective you could say oh he's
fulfilled the American dream
yeah I met my wife we had kids we built
this beautiful home in Malibu Canyon and
I was a entertainment lawyer as you
mentioned and so so it all looked right
you know everything kind of looked good
and the main thing that I really
overlooked through that that entire
period however was my help and my diet
and you know having been a swimmer in
college where I was training like three
or four hours a day every day you know I
would just eat whatever was in front of
me like the more calories the better and
I kind of prided myself on being able to
you know eat everyone else under the
table and how many cheeseburgers can I
can let's go to McDonald's and see you
can eat the most cheeseburger yeah I
love that and and I love fast food and I
developed my eating habits and my
approach to food were really kind of
formed and cemented by that experience
the problem is you know when my swimming
career ended my I was stuck with those
habits you know and they didn't do
anything to try to break them and
you know you can get away with it you
know when you're in 23 yeah you're
training for 3-4 hours a day or even
after you stop liking your young you can
still get away with that for a while
yeah and and you know my mom would
always say you got to watch out you know
heart disease runs in our family and you
know you can't just eat what you want
and it's like blah blah blah yeah the
other one you're young but the truth is
is that her father who has my name his
name is Richard also it was Richard
spindles and he had been a champion
swimmer at Stanford you actually
University admission pardon me
University Michigan swam at Stanford
that's right when I swam at Stanford it
was the best one team in the country
miss her couple aunts to a championships
I was training and swimming with like
Olympic gold medalists and world record
holders it was an amazing experience and
similarly and quite ironically my
grandfather Richard spindle was the
captain of the University of Michigan's
Michigan back in the late 1920s and a
time that was the number one swimming
program in the country and he had an
American record and he was an Olympic
hopeful he was like a contemporary of
Johnny Weiss Muller who was the great
you know swimmer of the day he was the
Michael Phelps of that era and despite
remaining active his whole life and
continuing to swim in his beloved Lake
Michigan you know during the warmer
months he wasn't a smoker he did he
wasn't it wasn't like overweight or
anything like that he died of a heart
attack
in his early 50:53 exactly and that was
when my mom was still in college and so
obviously he died long before I was ever
born yeah and and kind of you know a big
part of my story was really coming to
terms with like really kind of snapping
the denial and realizing that I was on a
similar path like I was going to you
know not only do I have his name live my
life very similarly the way he was
living his that I was probably headed
for the same similar outcome right so
what happened to kind of fast forward is
is yeah by the time I was 39 years old I
was 50 pounds overweight
you know my favorite foods were
cheeseburgers french fries you know
Domino's and Pizza Hut and Taco Bell
as we're mine at one point in time I
still I love that stuff it's Chia
fastest like what can I grab and get in
the car
bread and cheese you know eating was
always about like something I'd do on my
way to something else yeah exactly and
the faster and the easier and the more
cows get it out of the way
the better so yeah and I would have
happily continued to pursue that path
but what happened was on that even my
40th birthday I was 39 years old I had a
had sort of a rude awakening moment like
a little bit of a health care a health
crisis where I been up late watching
television my family was already asleep
I'd work late that night I came home
everyone was asleep I'm sitting on the
couch eating out of my bag of jacket box
or you know whatever it was yeah and
then it you know super late time to go
to bed start walking up the stairs to
our bedroom to go to sleep and just had
to stop like halfway up the staircase
like just out of breath sweat on my brow
I kind of buckled over tightness in my
chest and you know I didn't have a heart
attack but it was a scary moment where I
realize like wow like I'm 39 and like I
can't have like I had to take a break
eight stairs yeah like you know
something is not right it was one of
those moments where like my whole life
kind of flashed you know in my mind and
and and I realized like this is not I
need to course-correct here and I need
to do it like immediately like it I need
to do it now I need to do something
drastic
because if I don't I knew enough based
on an earlier experience I had with with
my addiction problems that if I didn't
do something immediately that kind of
that very precious special moment the
urgency of that moment would pass and I
would just say oh whatever and go back
to doing what I was doing just back into
the same old habits yeah I mean I think
we were talking about this earlier but
but I think that you know we all have if
you have one of these moments in your
life one of these kind of supercharged
two moments of urgency in your life
they're fantastic gifts they're
beautiful opportunities
you change and people say well people
don't change you know and maybe that's
true maybe most people don't but if you
have like kind of one of these moments
that I experienced well I guess I'll
backtrack when I was when I was uh in my
late 20s and early thirties I had a
terrible problem with drugs and alcohol
which he expounds yeah it shares a lot
more in the book the book is sort of
like million little pieces meets Lance
Armstrong it's not about the bike except
without that EPO yeah anyway so yeah
part of my story is an addiction story
and and you know I was when I was 31
years old I was blessed with like a
moment of clarity where I was willing to
kind of really snap out of my denial and
address the problem and you know a
little crack in the door happen for me
and I was able to walk through that and
ended up in rehab for a hundred days
where I really kind of like took a very
hard look at my problem and began to
address it and my life changed so by the
time I was 31 years old my life is a
disaster
I was unemployable I was alienated from
friends and family untrustworthy I was a
perpetual liar I could really rock
broadening and I was sleeping on a bare
mattress on the floor in a terrible
apartment with no furniture in it
yeah and I couldn't leave the house
without getting drunk it was vodka
tonics in the shower every morning and
drinking all day and drunk driving and
filing accidents and jails and you know
court dates and everything that comes
with that yeah at the time I didn't I
had tri course knew I was an alcoholic
and I died several times on my own to
try to get sober and clean up and every
time ended in failure and I thought I'm
just going to die a slow you know
desperate life of being a lonely
alcoholic and I was able to
through the grace of God and the help of
some other people come to terms of the
problem you know walk through a crack in
the door and go to rehab get sober and
my life change completely
life is a complete miracle as a result
of that one moment in time where I had
the willingness to do something
different yeah to kind of set aside my
preconceived notions surrender myself
completely to this problem and entertain
a new possibility a new a new
perspective a new way of living etc and
so when I was on fast-forwarding to that
moment on the staircase when I had that
kind of you know my life flashing before
my yeah moment and and was realizing
like I'm not on a good path I realized
that this was yet again like another
moment another one of those really
profound moments that had happened yeah
and I knew that I could change if I if I
grabbed on if you took a hold about it
um didn't before so yeah it was like a
blessing to be able to recognize that
because I know if I just sort of blew it
off or came up with some excuse for you
know why that happened and written it
off that maybe
I might have been not no going back so
the one thing that I really you know
Rich's book is very profound his life
story is is incredible and what he's
done since this moment that he's talking
to you about his really profound and
we're going to get into that right away
but that's one of the things I wanted to
share I really just want to highlight
here for everyone watching how are if
you're listening in to this you know all
of us are different different points and
our health goals all of us have
different things that we want to achieve
some of us it's more energy some of us
it's losing weight you know others it's
living with lifelong vitality but I
think it's a really profound moment I
myself had that moment at an earlier age
but I'd reached a point where I just
kind of I wasn't experiencing mentally
physically what I felt I wanted to or I
needed for my own health and wellness
and I I really had a profound moment
like that and I just decided to take
advantage of it and so for you if you're
listening or if you're watching this
just pay attention to that you know
doesn't have to be a moment where you
can't walk it up up 16 stairs aren't you
where to your room to go to bed but if
you have anything like that just kind of
I love the fact that rich is not only he
saw it but he took advantage of it and
he ran with it quite literally well I
think the point is is that you know for
me and my experiences I had to have I
did like experience like a certain level
of pain in order to get me to change
yeah Shane is the motivation I wish it
weren't all the time is you the point is
you don't have to suffer that in order
to change because know how are to change
resides within all of us all the time it
takes a commitment and it takes a
follow-through and there's a certain
kind of you know intensity at least in
the early stages about you know kind of
creating momentum around that but but
you know you can change you do have the
power to change and do not have to sort
of you know continue along the status
quo of whatever you're doing
if it's not serving them so on that note
continuing along the status quo so you
were 39 when you made sort of this
decision why don't you tell everyone
who's watching and listening to this
what you did after that so what I did
was I I decided well I decided I needed
to change my diet you know yes the first
thing my beloved you know McDonald's and
jack-in-the-box was going to have to you
know go by the wayside so the first
thing I did was I did a seven-day fruit
and vegetable juice cleanse which for me
is about as out of character as going
into my wife's closet and putting on a
dress and hike I am NOT at you know I'm
like a very you know logic-based
science-based guy yeah and so you know
when somebody some when a New Age person
says oh you should do a juice cleanse
and it will clean the toxins out of you
I'm like show me the proof where's the
evidence where it's in her reviewed
research that says that that's going to
happen and what toxins are we talking
about and how is this juice going to do
that and you know like I would just come
up with a million reasons why there's no
reason to do something like that but the
point is and it goes back to what I was
saying earlier was I was in a situation
where I was desperate enough to
surrender to a new way even if I maybe I
didn't agree with it or I couldn't
understand it completely I was like I
need to do something different than what
I'm doing now and if you were to say to
me why don't you just eat a little bit
better and go to the gym like maybe it's
because I have this extreme personality
or this addiction issue or whatever
those those are fine notions but they
don't mean anything to me because they
lack specificity they're just general
platitudes they're not they're not
they're not you know a roadmap for
action so maybe I need a little bit
better or go to the gym for a little bit
but I would I knew that I would devolve
quickly into my little patterns like I
needed something I could really latch on
to that was concrete and black and white
and so the juice lens is really my first
you know kind of stab at that and and I
did it with very low expectations just
all right I'll try this because what I'm
doing is not working and what I found
was that I mean the first couple days
I'm buckled over on the couch and it was
like I was packing rehab sweaty yeah
like I guess I am detoxing yeah I don't
think because I don't feel very good and
and you know my sleep was all messed up
and everything was you know it's felt
horrible but you talk about in the book
the fact that because you'd gone through
this rehabilitation thing which is funny
I never never before my life would I
ever thought have getting off of you
know junk food has a detoxification or
as you know one of these rehabilitation
processes but you talk about the fact
that because you've gone through that in
the past it kind of gave you the mindset
that you knew ok this is what's going to
happen I'm going to push through it I
know what this is I know what this feels
like
yeah weathering a detox like I've done
this before yeah I know that you know
this stinks right now but like if I
weather it out I'm gonna feel better and
sure enough by day 3 I started you know
this sort of cobweb started to go away
before actually felt really good like
day five I was like what happened like I
think out like a completely different
person my energy levels were through the
roof I had like a clarity of mind and I
felt more energized and vital than I had
in 20 years or maybe ever like I
couldn't I couldn't believe how good I
felt in such a short period of time and
really the message for me was it's just
amazing how resilient the human body is
that I can use it the way that I had so
profoundly for so long and then in a
mere matter of days and rebound and feel
this good this is a very powerful thing
for me you know even if let's say the
juice cleanse didn't remove any toxin
like I don't care because I felt
fantastic yeah cuz that I realized that
oh there really is that an equation
between you know food and health and
food you know food as medicine and you
are what you eat
things we always heard that you kind of
go yeah yeah but like I was like wow
it's a very direct you know you have
that realization within your cell show
and so then I thought well what am I
going to do now I have to start eating
the I can't just drink juice and forever
I've got to think so and I wish I could
tell you that that there were resources
like the future of health now or yeah
you know you know forks over knives
hadn't come out yet I didn't I could
have gone to the library and gotten a
bunch of books and study well what's the
best way of going forward from here and
yeah that's not really what happened I
kind of stumbled around and I the first
thing I did was I thought well I wonder
what happen if I tried a vegetarian diet
that sounds healthy and you know it
wasn't based on any research or anything
like that but again went for me and went
back to this idea of something being
concrete and black and white because in
recovery
in addition recovery you you know you
learn well you're either using drugs or
you're not
you're either you know you're either
drunk or you're sober there's no there's
no middle ground there's no like hey you
can have one drink it's very black and
white and there's something about that
that like you know that works for me
there's always edit Arianism you're the
eating meat or you're not and I could
relate to that like I could like I could
hold on to that and say this is like
something that I can grasp and so that's
what I did I you know I just cut the
meat out of my diet but you know I'm
also a lawyer and yeah loopholes and I
was like I can eat you know Domino's
Pizza is vegetarian right McDonald's
french fries are vegetarian yeah yeah it
wasn't long before I devolved you know
this whole thing kind of devolved on
back on the couch and you know of course
I didn't lose any weight I started to
feel lousy again and and you know even
though I was 50 pounds overweight I was
hardly a candidate for The Biggest Loser
I mean really what it was was my energy
levels were poor and it and that
affected everything like it affected my
you know my enthusiasm for anything
aspirational it affected you know how I
interacted with my kids like all of that
was very numbed and dull because I was
using those foods to kind of medicate my
emotion
and so I played that vegetarian thing
out and after six months I was like well
this isn't working and I was like well
you know I'll just bag it forget it I
tried yeah but I thought well I'm
halfway there I wonder what would happen
if I got rid of the dairy I got rid of
the processed foods and you know I
stopped looking for these loopholes and
so that was really the next step in the
evolution of this and again I did that
without very high expectations of
anything really changing but I just
thought I'll do this before I go back to
doing what I'm doing before just prove
to myself
prove to my wife that it wouldn't work
yeah exactly and again it was I had an
experience that was very similar to how
I felt in the juice glands like within
seven days of doing this really cleaning
up my diet eating entirely 100%
plant-based food to hide of eating you
know plant-based Whole Foods close to
their natural state I experienced that
resurgence and vitality that I had
during the cleanse and I realized while
there there's some validity this is
working for me because I feel really
really good which is incredible because
a lot of people you know rich and those
of you watching or listening to this if
you if you don't know who rich is yet we
haven't even gotten to the punch line
but the punch line the finish line but
but a lot of people don't associate you
know veganism or just eating plants or
fruits or vegetables or nuts or seeds
with strength or with health or vitality
in fact you know there was many many
times in my life before I had some of
this knowledge where I was adamant
adamant I have no idea why I didn't I
didn't have the knowledge to back up my
claims but I was adamant you absolutely
needed to eat meat for protein and you
were going to be weak and flimsy if you
weren't and one of the analogies which
makes in his book here is that you know
being a vegan is really only good for
kicking around a hacky sack or something
I mean how long is this interview
because I could talk about this subject
for hours yeah yeah I mean and I thought
I felt the same the same way I mean
we've sort of been raised to believe
that
you know if you want if you want strong
bones and strong muscles that you need
to eat dairy and drink milk drink milk
and you need to eat meat yep and all
this sort of thing and really what I've
what I've learned you know in the six
seven years that I've been doing this is
that a lot of that is you know they're
falsehoods in and a lot of it is
perpetrated and and it's perpetrated by
very powerful well-funded lobbying
groups from the you know from the Dairy
Council to you know the meat industry
want people to continue to believe it
you need those products and just rich
you know this is your we're just me you
know I've been sharing with you a little
bit about just tidbits about the future
of health now for a few a few months but
our biggest thing here at the future of
health now is just to share with you
information that's either evidence-based
as rich as demonstrated here in his life
or science-based for sure but as always
you know you don't have to believe any
of this stuff if there's anything that
you hear that you like feel free to
experiment with it in your own life and
if you get the results you're looking
for then you can kind of integrate it
that way as well so your own research
yeah I do your own research be critical
yes yeah in my experience you know we
we've all grown up with this message
pounded into into our minds you know
from the food pyramid that we were
taught when we were kids in school all
the way through adulthood
it's almost unquestionable this notion
that you need dairy for strong bones and
meat products for strong muscles and to
even question that is anathema and
certainly when I embarked on this
plant-based nutrition experiment at the
time I had no aspirations of becoming an
athlete again I just wanted to feel
better and have the energy level to
participate in my children's lives at an
optimal level that was really all I
wanted to lose a little bit of weight
feel better and stick around for a
couple more years nothing to do with
athletic performance in and you know at
that time I was like well yeah I mean
you know everyone says you need you know
you need milk for calcium and
need meat for strong strong muscles and
I don't know I feel pretty good like I'm
going to just play this out for a while
and see and I think that what I've
learned is is that you can be strong
very strong on a plant-based diet and
we'll get into a minute some of the
things I've done but certainly I've done
things as an athlete in my mid-40s that
I never would have dreamed possible when
I was 20 years old and a world running
swimmer at Stanford you know I've
exceeded the glass ceiling in my in my
athletic potential eating solely
plant-based diet and it made me take a
take a take a harder look and a more put
a more critical eye on these sort of
hard-and-fast notions of you know the
kind of foods that we standards of diet
thrive and you have to understand that
there are powerful business lobbying
interests at play that help craft and
promote these messages about what you
should what's healthy about to doing
your own research yeah and and you know
the FDA recently read what you see on
the front of food label well in the FDA
recently redid their their food plate
right the recommended food plate Harvard
changed theirs and tried to one-up but
essentially nothing had really changed
they're still grange they're still dairy
there's still me
Harvard at least put water on there like
drinking water and they they put it's
it's really tremendous but so that this
is a great the great thing to experiment
so let's talk about the evidence
supporting this experiment experiment in
your own life for you so what did you go
on to do you started training so you
went for a run it was really profound
the addition was being new to this
plant-based way of eating I suddenly had
all this extra energy and my body was
like a livewire literally like I needed
to do something just to burn off all
this extra energy that I suddenly was
experiencing and so you know I started
jogging occasionally and going to the
pool once in a while to just to jump in
and paddle around literally just to burn
off that energy calm myself down and
like ground myself a little bit
and thought I was enjoying it because
you always feel good right and that was
a big part of who I was as a kid yeah
kind of got lost in adulthood and that
you know it's part of kind of the
spiritual journey really of kind of
reconnecting with you know who you are
in a more authentic way and I realize
like you know I go to the pool and
paddle around and I realized you know I
love this I used to love this so much
and I haven't done it and so long so it
was it was really about rien gauging
that that part of myself that had gotten
lost and and the more I did it the
better I felt and but it was nothing
extreme you know I had the weight was
kind of slowly starting to come off and
I just was enjoying being in nature
really going on a trip casual jog trail
run here and there but down a couple
months into the this you know experiment
yeah I went out for a morning run on a
local trail near where I live in Los
Angeles and really was just going to run
for 45 minutes or an hour no big deal
and it was one of those days where
everything just clicked you know like
maybe you've had one of those days I
mean if you're a runner or an athlete or
you're an art like a painter or a
musician or anything that requires kind
of you know creating something out of
whole cloth where you have those days
you're in the zone and you're just
channeling it yeah happening I called
the flow the way yeah hello so I was
kind of having one of those experiences
on this run it was like the further I
went the better I felt I was just kept
running further and further away from
where I started and just it end and the
more with every step I felt more
energized and more alive and more
engaged in my environment and in my body
and I just like I'm gonna keep going and
I just kept going and going and finally
I was like two hours away from where
Hyde starts off in that direction I turn
around
out in the middle of nowhere like my
wife doesn't know where I am something
happens like I didn't bring any water
with me or anything like that and so I
was you know I wanted to keep going but
I was like I better turn around which
ran back towards the car and literally
like instead of running out of steam I
just felt great all the way to the end
and
and ended up running like a better part
of marathon that morning and I was like
what is going on you said in your brook
I think you read like 24 miles yes
something like that
and and I felt it great and I thought
did I just unlock some dormant gene
inside of me but it was undeniable that
this shift in the way I was eating was
certainly you know contributing to this
more than contributing instrumental if
not you know the defining reason because
I'd never done anything like that before
yeah and and and that's when I thought
you know now I really want to educate
myself more about the way that I'm
eating because there's really something
going something special happening here
and it also girded my resolve to kind of
look for a chin like it made me think I
want to challenge myself like I wonder
what this body but I treated horribly
for so long that now feels good like I
wonder what would happen if I really
kind of put it to the test and see what
it was capable of you know in as
somebody who's in their mid-40s and
that's when the kind of desire to find a
challenge in a race took place and you
know being 40 at the time you're like
well you know it's like the way that's
when you're looking for the bucket-list
thing maybe I'll do an Ironman you know
I friends that have done an Ironman yeah
that's like you know check the box yeah
did that kind of thing and and you know
I was interested in that but it was also
like so many people have done that and I
don't know how you know like it's it
seems really cool but it was missing
partner I guess it was missing kind of
like the sort of spiritual quest aspect
of it anything like a race like how fast
can we do this what's your time and I
was faster than you or can you qualify
for Conan all that kind of stuff and for
me it wasn't none of it was about that
it was just personal growth and and you
know
and kind of having an experience that I
hadn't had before in a different kind of
way I suppose it's hard to articulate
but then I read about this race called
Ultraman that I'd never heard of before
it was essentially a double the distance
of an iron triathlon that goes all the
way around the Big Island of Hawaii over
three days yeah and the Big Island
Hawaii is a Big Island it's a big Island
Connecticut
yeah and I was reading this article
about it and the way that this race was
described like hit every button that I
was looking for because it's just they
select 35 hand-picked people from around
the world to participate only 35 there's
no they don't close the roads there's no
you know aid stations everybody has to
bring their own crew very kind of like
you know there's no media there's no
coverage of the prize money there's none
of that and it's just about these
thirty-five people with their crews
going around this island over over three
days and supporting each other in that
and and there's something very honest
about that and that was different from
Ironman in that you know and this
article talked about how it was really
kind of this you know spiritual
experience it's journey of this communal
journey and in Hawaii they call it Ohana
you know CRO Honda's family and and even
though you know my crew members are
trying to help me if there's another
competitor it gets a flat tire like
they're gonna help them
yeah all in this together and it's not
really yeah it's a race and everybody's
pushing themselves to see how well they
can do but at the end of the day it's
less about who's winning and who's on
the podium than it is about Pat you know
making sure all 35 of us you know safely
traverse this massive you know
piece of land and get to the other side
intact and and when I read about it I
was like that's it that's that's the way
I'm gonna do which is insane so from 39
not being able to walk up eight stairs
before being winded and now is 40 he's
thinking about doing one of the most
intense adventure like long-distance
races it's ludicrous thinking back in
the world I had to call that you can
consider that that would be Paul so can
you tell some of the specs from the
event just so we know because um so
Ultraman is three like I said as a three
day race to three days it's kind of like
the Tour de France they race a day and
they sleep and they get up the next day
so the first day is a 6.2 mile ocean
swim swim in the oceans and I bet you
there's currents in the in the ocean off
of the Big Island a lot of not always in
your favor and then you you so you swim
from you start it the pier in Kona which
is if you've watched the Ironman World
Championships on TV it's the same place
where they start that race but instead
of going in a loop and getting out there
you swim some south down the shore and
get out in Khao Bay which is 6.2 miles
to get out you get on your bike and then
you ride 90 miles 90 miles there's a lot
of wind the last 20 miles you're doing
this 4000 foot climb up to volcano
National Park so the last 20 miles
you're literally going it's just the
wind blowing and you're going really
slow and it's a backbreaker so that's
day one day two you wake up and you ride
170 miles around the other side of the
island and you end up in a little town
called Javy shaman north west end of the
island
and the third day you run fifty two
point four miles from hobby back into
the town of Kona where the race began
it's incredible so it's cool it's a very
very special race and I'm like I said I
don't know what it was but it was like
maybe you've had those moments in your
life where you see something in your
life that's the path I'm supposed to be
on yeah
it just feels right just yeah there's no
there sistent intuition you don't really
question it based on logic yeah
understanding or anything like that if I
can say anything to everybody out there
you know I think we're going to we live
in a culture in a society where somebody
has that kind of Flash or whatever we're
just our instinct is to like push it
aside or say oh that doesn't make any
sense you know back to the cubicle or
whatever you know pay attention to those
things like just just sort of acting on
that little impulse change my life
completely
yeah there's such dramatic ridiculous
ways that it would have been easy for me
to just kind of go oh well I'll never do
that or that doesn't you know that
doesn't really fit in to the way I see
my life or what have you okay because it
didn't make sense and you know I called
up the race director after I read that
article yeah I want to do this race and
she's like okay hey what have you done
like I haven't done anything and she
could have said well why don't you call
me in a year yeah why do you do like why
do you run a marathon why don't you try
an Ironman or yeah experience and then
call me we thought about it but she was
said well you know it means a lot that
you called and you know we're not even
accepting the applications yet and and
why don't you just you know call me in a
couple months and let me know and
we'll take it from there so in other
words she didn't say no she said no I
would have said okay I tried yeah but
she kind of another door cracking open
yeah and I was like it was all I need
and I was just like I'm getting into
that race I don't care you know was she
said enough and I just started training
and preparing as if I'd already been let
in and sure enough she did ultimately
succumb and let me into the race and you
know I I only had six months to train
for that race and shut up you know I'm
starting line in 2008 for that like the
Bad News Bears was like the crew was
like my dad none of us knew anything
about what we were doing yeah and and my
only goal really was to finish without
dying like just die now I'm dying is a
good goal for an adventure race race I
was doing it to compete celebrate how
much my life had changed but if my diet
celebrates having had 10 years of
sobriety you know and and enjoy it
really and and that's what I did but I
ended up exceeding my expectations I was
like eleventh in that race so I end up
doing really well I was like wow wonder
what would happen if I spent a whole
year training and went back the next
year and actually rather than being all
timid and worrying about dying like
actually tried to race it yeah and you
finished what place overall the first
time 1111
okay so 11th overall I just really want
to highlight this for everyone that's
listening because rich roll hadn't
really done any training for anything
like this ever before in his life
never II was a competitive swimmer 20
years prior but not in running not in
biking runner never no never never raced
a bike or anything never raced it never
raced a bike never never raced running I
competed in this race 35 of the the top
athletes in this kind of an event in the
whole world and he came 11th overall
11th in 2008 11th and 2008 overall as a
vegan and you know I I've never been a
very strong competitive athlete but the
little I know about athletics is that
mostly if ever you mentioned the fact
that you're a vegetarian or a vegan to
to most people that are athletes you
pretty much just get made fun of you
know there's no protein how do you do
that 11th overall so this is a real
testimony
I think you're onto something here you
know this point you're definitely you're
proving that there's some evidence
behind this right and I think what I've
learned along the way is that a there's
there's plenty of protein in plants some
plants are higher in protein than others
but eating a well-rounded
you know variety of plant-based foods
you are going to meet your protein needs
no matter you know whether you're a
sedentary person or your training 20 to
25 hours a week which is what I was
doing and I was continuing to get
stronger leaner faster more powerful all
of those things on eating just plants
the second thing is and I think this is
sort of a secret weapon kind of
advantage of eating a plant-based diet
that I don't think enough attention is
paid to as an athlete the key thing they
are always looking for and trying to do
is maximize your recovery time yes train
but what we don't think about enough is
that that you make those gains and those
strides and improvements in a period of
time in between your training sessions
in that resting period and if you and if
you can repair you if you can expedite
the period of time it takes to repair
your body from one training session to
the next by eating you know foods high
in antioxidants by you know eating foods
that are anti-inflammatory then you are
going to be able to train harder pack
more training sessions into a short
period of time and that extrapolated
over a period of a season or a year that
will result in performance gains and
when you're eating a plant-based diet
it's very alkaline form and then that
means is you are it's anti-inflammatory
and it's also create it's also well to
backtrack the standard American diet the
standard American lifestyle is very acid
for me so our body works very hard to
maintain a relatively neutral pH right
when we're eating the standard American
diet and we're breathing in pollution
and we're in a high-stress job all of
those things contribute to too
what we call chronic acidosis where your
body is being inundated by these
quote-unquote acids and you have to work
your body host it is stressed and
working overtime to neutralize that pH
bring it back to neutral and when you
when you're in this this acidic kind of
environment that's that's an environment
that's right for getting sick or
congenital disease you know you know you
know people are always sick all within
them or whatever a lot of it can be
linked to inflammatory you know foods
that promote inflammation and acid
forming you know foods that have an acid
forming impact on your on your blood pH
so when you're eating a plant-based diet
is very alkaline forming and this is a
easier on your body it's easier on your
body it is you know it helps keep your
immune system strong so you're not
getting sick and losing training for
that and it really and I found that it
expedites the amount of time it takes my
body to recover in between workouts so
it's pretty a pretty good advantage if
you're training for something like an
Ultraman yeah so it's not like people
say well you did it despite being a
vegan or eating a Sikh and I and I'm
like no actually like that was a
contributing factor in my success and
yeah heartedly believe that yeah and
since then so since then rich went on to
compete again in 2009 is that correct
yeah so I went back to that race in 2009
and after the first day I had a
10-minute lead on the field oh yeah day
one he was in the lead by 10 minutes
which is in a sport like that the little
I know is that's like a year you know
it's like people win those races by
Seconds and sometimes minutes is that
crazy experience because literally from
you know a hundred yards into the swim I
took the lead and I didn't see any other
competitor the entire day
Wow I was just looking behind me the
whole time when are they going to catch
me when is that riding up the volcano at
the end going I remember he's gonna pass
me any minute I know it like I don't
deserve to in your book you talk about
this Brazilian gentleman you're like I
just expect him to be coming up and just
racing it I had I'm looking back
everything where is he he's coming and
yeah I won the first day about 10
minutes which was huge unbelievable like
the highlight of my you know I thought a
career unfortunately the second day 35
miles into the 170 mile bike I crashed
my bye
broke my pedal and and my knee was all
swollen I shared all the skin off my
shoulder was on a section of road where
they don't allow the crew vehicles to
traverse so I had to kind of slowly get
up and pedal like a mile on one leg to
the end with one pedal with one pedal
yeah blood everywhere it's raining out
and I thought that you know my race is
over I can't do this on one pedal and my
knees all swollen yeah you know forget
it and during that this is kind of
important I think is during that kind of
1 mile
you know period I'm just getting used to
the idea that like I don't have to
finish this yeah gracefully bow out of
this race yeah
nobody's gonna bat an eyebrow yeah I can
go to the beach later yeah you're
talking about the sheets of the hotel
room you're already getting ready he was
already getting ready to go back to the
hotel thinking about how comfortable the
sheets were gonna be and talking about
how there's switches that could flick
like a switch got flicked where I was
mentally done I was done with this race
and I get to the end of the road and and
you know I see my wife and she's like
it's gonna be ok and I was like let's
just pack the bike in the car get out of
here and a crew member firm for another
athlete came up and looked at my bike
he's like what kind of pedal was that I
told him and he disappeared and he came
back a minute later with a brand new
pedal the exact same bow that I needed
to grab my bike he put the pedal on he's
like you're not done you got to finish
it you get back on your bike and finish
this thing on a 170 mile understand like
I've done I've already given up I gave
up a mile ago you didn't know everybody
passed me I'm now way behind and I can't
really move my knee and that that's
going to be pretty mentally mentally
daunting right no internet it comes down
to very small margins like try to get
your head back in the game yeah like
checking out like that and being in
physical pain yeah I don't know how I
did it I crushed my bike here and quite
a couple weeks ago and it wasn't nearly
as bad as that crash and I remember
thinking after I went down
and I was like how did I do that at
Ultraman dock my bike you know thank so
much adrenaline is probably yeah there's
a lot of adrenaline and I think so for
me then you know I kind of soldier
through that day as best I could and I
was able to get through the double
marathon run the next day and ended up
getting sixth overall in the race it's
incredible and people say well yes I
ended up salvaging in it but you could
potentially have won it's you know it's
up in the air but I don't know but but
that pitch will say like aren't you
upset like do you know do you think you
could have won do you think you could
have been on the podium and for me it
doesn't matter I have to remember like I
think about is that first time I read
that article about that race and what
attracted me to it was the sort of
personal journey and if everything goes
great in a race what do you learn about
yourself learn that much it's sort of
like when that when I crash and I had to
get back on my bike and finish that that
was where that was the greatest thing
that could have happened that was
exactly what I was looking for out of
that experience because I learned more
about myself and what I'm capable of and
you know barriers that I could break
through personally not just doesn't
athlete but just you know mentally
emotionally spiritually then I could
have ever experienced had everything
just gone great and I raced you know
perfectly well nothing bad happens no in
my mind it was a perfect race and the
perfect experience I wouldn't change a
thing about anything well it's really
beautiful so rich having shared with us
the story it's it's really an
inspirational story for me rich thank
you very much I've never I've always
thought about maybe doing an Ironman I'm
not sure about an Ultraman but I don't
even really run right now you if I could
even just accomplish it or you're young
if I could even just accomplish an
Ironman I would be really grateful or
even a marathon but that's a very
inspirational story we here at the
future of health now in many of these
interviews we need to incorporate more
fruits more plants more vegetables I
we've never yet had anyone on yet to
date that shows us that we can do these
things and achieve such great feats of
physical mental endurance and stamina
but rich I just really wanted to thank
you very much for being here thanks for
everything that you're doing to help the
lives of myself and all of our viewers
and all of our listeners to live happier
healthier lives now and well into the
future
if I could just leave the viewers with
one phone yes please do this is not
about being perfect and I think like the
idea of eating a plant-based diet is
intimidating the people because yeah I
think if they fall off the wagon or it's
just it's too hard or whatever and I
think that it's important for people to
like let go of that yeah about a label
it's not about like who I'm a vegan or
I'm not a vegan or anything like that
just eat more plants just eat more whole
food Whole Foods plant-based foods close
to their natural state incorporate more
of that into your life into your daily
habit and like pay attention to how you
feel yeah let's get advice we could all
we could all stand to benefit from that
so thank you very much for watching or
listening to this once again my name is
a Rui Beckman and we were here with rich
role from rich Volcom is that correct
role doc rich worldcom the rich world
podcast and thank you very much once
again for listening and watching this is
the future of health now right Sirois
you're welcome to be here yeah